i'm at the brea improv right now in
california come see the babes um we got
i'm in san francisco uh september 8th to
the 10th at the uh cobbs comedy club
that's going to be fun for fun then we
got madison wisconsin milwaukee
wisconsin chicago and minneapolis all at
chrisdcomedy.com and who knows the uk
might be on sale soon christy comedy.com
ooh uk uk i think it might be on sale
right now we're not sure that's crazy
talk okay all my fall dates are up we're
starting again in october there's a
couple dozen dates up i'm going to
florida i'm going to california i'm
going to canada i'm going to evansville
indiana louisville and everywhere in
between second shows in hershey
pennsylvania atlanta georgia and toronto
right now everything's on sale at salvo
county comedy.com
san jose where my family's from i'm
visiting you in december i'd like for
you guys to come out
really i really appreciate it you got
one of your cousins lost a lot of weight
out there
savilecanoecomedy.com my nephew that
guy's great kid he lost a hundred pounds
but
nephew's second cousin removed or a
nephew no my straight-up nephew god and
he does jiu-jitsu he's ripped yeah come
see me on tour
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate hey ian fire dance here at
ianimal69 on instagram check out my
brand new podcast b and ian with jordan
patreon.com
b and pod the episode that comes out
tomorrow i'll tell you
me tommy pope chris o'connor and that's
right
lenny dykstra you guys know
nails nails came to my apartment in my
studio and hung out for two and a half
hours and then we ate chicken sandwiches
up the street it was the craziest thing
just stay on the podcast just stay on
twitter
back-to-back weeks bro you want to do an
80s huh you want to do another apple
juice
he's gonna do two hours with fine dance
it's part a part b with finance because
he's bisexual it's like his sexuality
yeah we did one episode for each of the
genders yeah yeah this is a gay one this
one's a stray horn
puppy
so you had lenny
nails on dykstra i can call him right
now we are now friends
i can you call lenny dykstra can we call
him and ask just we're not going to say
anything who you are just ask him don't
if he likes to show the impractical
jokers or ask me if he likes to podcast
hey babe first
that's so funny wait is he like is he
what's how would you describe him in
three sentences
lucid introspective insane okay
three one word sentences he's got a oh i
thought you meant three words lucid
introspective and insane is the three
words yes wow that's interesting bro it
was in it was crazy because he has his
reputation and being this [ __ ]
lunatic animal like he showed up to my
house literally he has a weird
reputation recently yeah yeah he's an
inmate he's a criminal oh he is he's a
criminal yeah that's him right now
come on in then when those calls when
that food comes you just throw it at us
bring in lenny dykstra and this is your
life
it he shows up to my house and he goes
hey
did you bring the because i brought my
teeth
wow he has fake teeth the day before he
calls we're on the phone he goes so so
the podcast is there um can we say
in cussing and i'm like yes lenny
there's [ __ ] and cussing you can wait
wait wait he specifically said can i can
we say
and cuz
yeah yeah i say cursing do you ever say
i say cussing you say
curse words dude he he was so great so
nice did you make the connect how did
you how did he end up on your fully
connect right it's got to be no well i
the the uh booker fukumia
tried to connect me and him
it's like
everything's coming up
yeah and and i tried to get him on argue
garbage and they like scoffed they were
like this guy's a lunatic he's like
being all over the place no and i like
spoke dijkstra i guess because i was
like yeah surely lenny dykstra and are
you garbage would have been a home run
yeah
but on granny and it was a grand slam
damn it but dude he was talking about
when he fought rick dempsey at home
plate he was talking about how he got on
steroids he was talking about like
coming up in the majors being with the
86 mets he told some insane story about
how oh he gave us the formula on how you
stay up doing coke all night and
still play a day game and go five for
five like what do you
baby foreign baby formula yeah
pythagorean theorem is the formula yes
formula squared plus b squared equals
two squared c squared
no i think it's a little more than that
no okay well that is what it is well the
pythagorean theorem is a squared plus b
squared equals c squared yeah that's it
right yeah
okay yeah maybe i'm thinking the greek
is saying yes oh i'm talking to
something else oh what'd we get this is
a big equation
whoa oh
oh my god what is wow is that pecan pie
yeah you got it
wow
this is so nice i'm good baby i'm good
you're not gonna have anything babe come
on i have the thing let's okay thank you
let's lady and the trumpet sal come on
all right fine this is the straight
episode what is this one
oh a lemon tart switching because she
said i know you're a tart oh look at
that
i love a dessert that has to scotch tape
the lid on yeah that's a fun place also
i don't know if i'm supposed to just
chomp it down or do i use fork a knife
well it's it's in a tart right so it
looks like you can handle it with your
hands
let me tell you something you can do
whatever you want you're sitting on the
couch that pete davis and kim kardashian
used to have sex on so you can swear to
god that was your house
uh i defer i don't i don't know we don't
know oh
allegedly
i honestly
i don't know how you want to eat that
but you could take it up with bloom cafe
oh my god jesus nice placement you're
getting all the bits
i'll it will take me the entire episode
to get this open let me know over here
dude
a millisecond later
that was the easiest thing in the world
dude where
so it was so so is he did he mismanage
his money or is he still well well off i
i don't know anything about that all i
know is that he was like
the financial guy jim cramer was like
he's the man
and then [ __ ] went under when the
financial crisis happened i don't know
if it was his fault or [ __ ] whatever
but wait wait wait jim cramer how did he
get involved what did you say benjamin
dude on mad money he like vouched for
lenny he was like this guy's the future
i don't know how that happened oh like
back in the day of ball playing no no
this was lenny quit lenny was known as a
money guy yes
oh that i didn't know bro he was like
top-tier money investor oh i asked that
just in general no idea lost it all went
to jail he owned wayne gretzky's house
bought it from him they foreclosed on
and he took a [ __ ] on the living room
floor carpet before he moved out oh my
god wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait you're gonna have to back that
up yeah
say that again
he bought wayne gretzky's house okay
it got foreclosed on and before he left
he [ __ ] on the floor is like a few to
them
on the podcast he goes i'm a nice guy i
don't start fights but i'll [ __ ] end
them
like wow
he would like to tell these stories and
then give him a side
like he he was talking about like he uh
he like somebody at because he was like
a little guy when he joined the mets
uh he had to like prove himself and some
guy was like hey is that the batboy he
goes batboy i'm the best [ __ ] one
here i'm lenny dykstra and jim mcafee
you know jim mcafee he's a nudist now
and we're like what
no no you changed
it yeah yeah literally throws [ __ ] out
there yeah and you're like wait dude he
told a story about how we're talking
about like you never know uh when you're
gonna die he goes yeah you might die at
second base you're like what and he goes
i was all uh oh and he called cocaine
keith richards
he called richard he told a story about
doing coke it's robert de niro playing
keith's richard's greatest hits it was
the most surreal thing i've ever been a
part of lenny i used to carry his
baseball card in my wallet yeah right
right
he was my hero yeah
my dad's truck the number was the
license plate said four because four was
his number my number literally he also
stole bases right he was fast right yeah
correct me
well he was all right he was an all-star
he was an all-star dude he is but on the
mats he stole bases didn't he yeah dude
won the world series with the 86 mets
yes
in the 93 world series he like went five
for i go didn't you go five for five
with like don't you have a postseason
record he goes yeah i'm third behind two
other guys luff
garrick and joe dimanche everyone say
jeter get the help
i mean in a way it's not i'm now is he
is he is he still in shape well no now
he's now he's he's on he's on orange
juice now yeah yeah
so how many years did he do in prison
dykstra i i don't know but dude in like
91 or 92 he hit 400 like he he hit 400
400 seasons for for an an entire month
straight okay four hundred yeah he
talked about how he spent five hundred
thousand dollars hiring private
investigators to get dirt on umpires so
that they would
shrink the strike zone so he could get
more walls you're kidding me he told
that whole story [ __ ]
it's like some gangster [ __ ] bro it's in
i'm telling you you gotta watch your
podcast and i'm not just like plug my
pocket it's like truly it's the most
surreal thing i've heard what's the
podcast called again being ian with
jordan patreon.com beanie and
we'll all go watch it
it's truly insane i i gotta watch this
he was arrested again in 2018 for
threatening the life of an uber driver
yeah and possession of cocaine and
ecstasy yeah
he does he's done that but he's been off
opiates since like 98 and he told how he
went to israel and did this insane
jewish
he like loves jews because an israeli
guy saved his life getting him off
opiates he did this rapid detox thing
that was experimental at the time yeah
that doesn't mean he should like all
jewish people well i mean who does i
mean just like when there's one bad
person you don't blame everybody
everybody yeah yeah and vice versa i
mean dude he's going to do about jewish
people
shout out jewish people love jewish
people my favorite jew besides jesus i
would say number one jewish person be
after jesus paul rudd wow
that's a pull paul rudd is is i'm in
love with him
as a matter of fact paul we send in paul
writer's ant-man to save crime here
he could do it what about when he's
straight
right into the cartridge
i told you i just had dinner with him no
he did say this
i was thinking of him
yeah he's the best he makes me feel like
a natural woman yeah
i'd be paul rudd is so cute to me that
if i was having dinner with him it'd be
tempting to just take a bite out of him
yeah i'd want to cut a piece of his body
i'd be like i'm all good with the menu
and i just like when i found out he was
in ghostbusters afterlife i was so giddy
with joy i feel like he's the next tom
hanks or something yes paul rudd is the
next guy he's still loved he is there's
not one person he doesn't love the guy
he doesn't age he's at least 50. and
everything we hear about him is he just
like the kindest guy kindest kindest
his parents are british
53. look how good he looks
he does look great for 53. and his if
he's because he's a small guy his mother
must be tiny
he towers over his mom
so that's your favorite jewish person
besides jesus
okay wow wow i don't have anything
recently we learned his parents are
cousins i i think mine is default lately
david what
rudd recently learned his parents are
second cousins that's like technically
illegal second cousins yes
that's the key to beauty
that's the key then because he's
good-looking yeah because first cousin's
not good dude
i gotta [ __ ] my cousin
really
really okay
you're attracted to your cousin
okay
what's the relation
second or third well the big difference
i
got when i was drinking
her name and another girl's name were
mixed up and i was drunk and i sent some
very dirty texts to i who i thought was
some girl i just met but it was to my
cousin
and it was awkward because of what i
said and also the fact that i would have
done it to her
[Laughter]
no her response was like i think you
were the wrong number and i was like oh
i'm so sorry i'll see you at christmas
yeah yeah yeah never really spoke did
you ever bring it up again never really
what's a third cousin what's a second
cousin okay so i think what a second
cousin is yeah is if you're my cousin's
kid yes yeah then what's the third
customer it can't be your cousin's kids
kids
that's what it is the kids so when i'm
90 i have a third cousin in my cousin's
kids kids
so let's say ian and i are cousins yes
and our kid is your
first guest your parents are sisters ian
is ian is your father you're my second
cousin wait what ian's my f oh if you're
brothers no we're cousins okay we're
cousins
this is your son you're first he's my
first cousin you're that's your son
we're second cousins okay but now you
have a daughter who's venetia venetia's
my third cousin can't be third cousin
though
no
okay here we go now
it never helps it's just doesn't make
sense
okay let's read let's go to you let's
let's make here's you yes
okay we have kids okay so your parents
i don't understand what this is i don't
understand it
you have children you have grandchildren
your parents your sibling is your niece
and your
oh your your
oh really so my nephew's kids are my
grand nephews
right
my
son's kids
are my grand nephews
that's crazy i didn't know that
i have no clue what's going on
grandparents wedding trying to figure
out
so i can really think brittany grineer
is having an easier time in russian
prison right now when we are trying to
figure out this job hold we were wrong i
could read it right here we were wrong
a first cousin
wrong we're wrong
what if they say britney you are out of
this jail you just have to explain the
cousin charge by memory
and she's like i can do it if you give
me some weed
so so so what happens is this if i'm his
boy if i'm his
young good boy
you're my first cousin once removed
and my kid is your first cousin twice
removed see that but why are they
removed they're there it's once removed
from you
so you're his first cousin i'm in your
lineup okay i get through his cousin
once removed first once removed from the
source but why are you doing this yeah
but but where are we getting to but
forget about the removed what am i just
your second or third cousin proper i'll
tell you right now i'm reading this it's
your grandparents
siblings yes your grandparents siblings
are your
second cousin correct
correct what if i have no grammar no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
siblings my aunts and uncles yeah this
isn't right wait hold on that means that
you it says okay you so your
grandparent's
brother or sister is your grand uncle or
aunt that makes sense that makes sense
because your parents
your parents sibling is your aunt or
uncle so your grandparents signals are
your grand aunt or grand uncle yeah okay
so their kid
is
your
parents
first cousin once removed but your
second cousin oh no their kids are our
first cousin once removed
which one of these people can i legally
have sex with all of them
well if you're going going by him he's
talking about the last column
okay
this is wild bro
do you get it oh no you i don't
understand i'm looking at you and trying
to figure it out from there but that
makes it even worse for me you're
growing how do i get to my sister
this is like aberdeen costello
wait did you did your grandparent any
grandparent do you know has a brother or
sister
yeah yeah okay i called my grandmom's
sister aunt cookie that's wrong she's
your first cousin once removed
look at that you've been lied to oh no
no no no no no your grandma's sister is
your grand aunt you're right so your
grandma dad but you can't took his kid
is you're still your first cousin once
removed
your your grandma yes cousin yeah okay
okay here it is ready your your aunt
tooky your grandmother's sister
her
grandchild is your second cousin that's
what that says
then how would we get to his third so
then that was the second cousin i wanted
to stop
so you wanted to you want to have sex
with your auntie's your grandmother's
sister's
granddaughter that's it that's it look
at the chart your grandmother's
sisters
granddaughter two down generation my
second cousin my second cousin once
no
no it's it's the orange box right there
generation five one would really throw
this in a wrench if you would figure
this all out but then i threw in a
[ __ ] thing and i said what if one of
these first cousins second cousins goes
trans
then they definitely gotta [ __ ] him
you're screwed
why because that's your life
nephew's nieces look at this one
i bet you you can't translate people are
nephew once removed
well biological are we talking
biological nephew or biological needs
look if you go down seven generations
your great grandparents is brothers and
sisters you can get to a third cousin
twice removed that person you got to be
able to [ __ ]
you should be able to i kind of think
like they're hap
like so we might i don't even know who
that person is nobody keeps tabs on that
family like that my great grandparents
is
siblings
great great grandchildren
no idea you're gonna [ __ ] that you don't
know who that person is you you probably
already did what oh my god life hack if
you're adopted you can [ __ ] them all
that's true that's absolutely true you
can [ __ ] your dad that's literally the
only thing why not
yeah if you're adopted you can literally
have sex with anybody there is 1 000 an
adopted child out there that that has
had open loving willing sex with their
parents yeah it's called woody allen
yeah it's called what it's called
yeah that was all we adopted that girl
that was big to do yeah yeah yeah yeah
for a while five decades to do that yeah
yeah yeah
did you guys see uh gordon ramsay was
getting canceled for this video what
happened you can't cancel gordon ramsay
he has 50 shows on the air
is he going to just slaughter a lamb
does he make the lamb do blackface
what is he doing
tell me he's just going to jump in there
and snap that lamb's neck i swear to
christ
you
oven time
it is a little sadistic you know yeah
oh he yelled oven time yeah at the end
and then
he wouldn't count but at the end when he
went over time he did throw up a hell
well he did go which was the
yeah everything was fine until then why
was he goose stepping in that cage
also i mean read the room those things
are adorable
and you're you're like putting your
hands together like you're the wicked
witch of the east and tell them which
one you're gonna throw says hansel and
gretel thought this was a good idea to
post if anything he should be in there
oh i mean this is just brutal yeah but
give me a break that he's going to get
canceled vegan teacher say this he found
the lamb where's the lamb sauce yeah i
don't think he's really getting canceled
i mean well i mean they're going after
beyonce this week what are they going
into beyonce because she's she's
slaughtering
anyone anyone slaughtering lambs these
days anyone can't beating lamb to
slaughter interesting no how they going
into beyonce i love how one guy goes
gordon ramsay keeping it real as usual
he's he's my favorite chef
he's the he's the chef that keeps it the
most real for me
well beyonce used the word spares and
you're not allowed to say spazzing
you're allowed to say whatever you want
this is america yeah so spazz is bad
yeah isn't it spasm [ __ ] or whatever
it is apparently you can't say because
of cerebral palsy
oh
[Laughter]
because in the 1980s it was literally on
t-shirts yeah right and you don't know
that you're not supposed to say it how
can you get in trouble it just just we
need to we we need to learn here's the
problem we need to educate and i said
there's now i just found out that that's
beyonce's hat
yeah
it looks like it looks like a black lace
chip look at her [ __ ] hat yeah that
is that is there's a black pringle on
her head
i mean what the [ __ ] that is hi
couture right here
they should not bow down to these
[ __ ] that go take out the lyric
from your song she should go
no
then just [ __ ] it move on don't do it uh
has anybody else heard
rap music for the last 40 years yeah
she's saying drill
we're worried about the word spaz when
guys are literally bragging about
murdering people and yeah
gonna do it she already removed the word
lizzo did the same thing what did lizzo
do now she broke a stage because she's
fat
uh
elizabeth
lizard bit up wait why
change his lyric because of the word
what is an ableist slur lizzo's got
ableist lyrics hold my bag do you see
this [ __ ] i'm a spam well that's a bad
thing so she also said spaz and beyonce
did in the same week no this this a
couple months i think yeah
dude
how is that a slur
if that is a slur
you should be you should be putting
gordon ramsay's own but oven
yeah you should be lamb
hey lizzo please remove the word spazz
from your new song i genuinely believe
and i've said this on stage that i don't
think these are real people i think
they're russian bots to do this yes to
cause division to cause
yeah so instead we're talking about
spazz on hey but we're not talking about
this right real quick that article will
will literally pull something with no
retweets and no likes and put it as a
source yes
they did that in ohio they're a russian
troll farm we know for a fact that we're
russian troll farms we know that
facebook
is a funny word
yeah i work at the russian gold farm
toilet toiling away yeah
i'm in charge of the irrigation system
did you guys see the spies they caught
in hawaii that hawaiian is interesting
this is pretty crazy i cannot believe
those two are they british here's the
thing we know about cambridge analytica
how it was that massive breach of data
right so they get all people's faces
information they use that to the russian
troll farms put that as twitter profiles
to make it look like it's a legitimate
person yes come up with a bunch of
[ __ ] word salad we think it's real
and then it's a larp that turns into
reality right that happened in ohio they
had a [ __ ] muslim day parade in a
fake facebook group that they made up
and then they made an anti-muslim
facebook group legitimately had real
humans show up because of this fake
facebook group it's all [ __ ] fake
that's what i think nope is about how
you don't think it is yes i think i
don't see it but i read it staying away
from technology not looking don't don't
engage with social media because when
the alien comes i didn't see it i didn't
see it
god
said so we can't say it i had an idea
that something like that it was gonna
happen listen
tell me in the water
and they all should want to tell them
wait
i've been to the ocean i'm sharing some
secrets but look they stole people's
identities and they were spies yeah
that's what's happening what country
this is real pimp uh believe it russia
you wanna watch it's pretty interesting
can we get flagged no you'd be good it's
a new story are you positive though are
you positive we've watched i don't want
to lose someone just don't worry about
these people i don't want to lose them
new stories these people look like let's
watch this painting of those two farmers
the guy on the left looks like a spaz oh
she looks good
hey
look they both look creepy though they
both look creepy they do look crazy they
both look like they have sticky
genitalia do you oh yeah and coffee
breasts yeah do you think do you think
in your life do you think a spy has
walked right by you yes right gotta be
like i would say yes a spy of some type
i mean it might be a shitty spy but i do
think a spy's watching so you've been
around a spy you think you think you've
ever spoken to a spy
we had a cia spy come and speak at my
high school well i mean high school
because he was out there i mean like an
undercover like a spy
just you crossed in real life and you
even if you exchange pleasantries like
oh i'll get that thank you
like speaking to my cigarettes
i don't think so no how common you think
a spy is
do you think how many out of every how
many people is a spy one out of every
one one out of a million
a million one out of a million so you'd
say there's 500 supplies in the united
states
yep
okay i don't think there's any more than
500 spots there is no i think there are
no physical spies but they're spying
online yeah and everything is stolen and
regurgitated and
what i wasn't far away wow spies are
living among us spies if you're watching
and we know that you are you are we're
about to out you right now spies are
living among us in the united states
alone one expert estimates that there
are about 100 000
foreign
60 to 80 nations spying on america you
said 500. he said a million i was off
what what are they reporting back what
are they like
hello yeah
hello they are getting fatter
what do they have to say
google famous people who are thought to
be spies there's some names on this list
that's going to blow your mind there's a
lot of people
throughout life that they think were
spies joe derosa okay that means one
that those numbers chris are one in
every five thousand what
one in every five thousand people is a
spy which means if you go to a sell sold
out yankee game just then spence buys
there no yeah well they
no there was somebody who i was like
hey lou
she's getting who's the most famous spy
awesome power nobody i heard i don't
know any of them i guess that makes them
a good spy yeah
all right go back to this let's listen
to the hawaiian spot bobby edward fort
and gwen dahl morrison aka julie lynn
montag are accused of being russian
spies they're charged with identity
theft lying on their passport
applications and conspiracy to commit
crimes against the u.s
i think at this point what you're
looking at in the charging documents is
preliminary charges to get these people
off the streets and begin negotiating
with them and seeing what they know and
what is their willingness to cooperate
with the us government if they are not
willing to play ball stay tuned for some
very serious charges coming their way
pictures of the two apparently in kgb
uniforms oh shot how would you know dude
you're doing a broadcast for your
[ __ ] living
yeah tom simon's giving me updates on
the spies you're literally doing the
[ __ ] broadcast from your base when
you piece of [ __ ] what could these
[ __ ] losers it look like they worked
the pharmacy at a [ __ ] walgreens
they definitely they wear sketchers yeah
yeah yeah i love that like this guy the
guy in hawaii was a spy and they're like
how did you find out he had a picture of
himself dressed up as one in his living
room
i mean
he's literally dressed like a like a
cartoon character
it literally is what they like what
soldiers look like in a looney tunes
carter
[Laughter]
also the balls on that spot to get
detained and smile like that let me know
in his photos he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he's like i know again
guys look at the pictures smiling yeah
she was like oh [ __ ]
oh my god someone just took a picture of
me as a spy [ __ ]
look at these if i don't blink they
can't tell by nothing i literally
couldn't look more like russian [ __ ]
spy they're dressed in full russian like
1990 ussr uniforms insane
in this picture she's literally eating a
boot
[Laughter]
she's smiling too
how creepy is that
fraudulently enlisted in the coast guard
in 1990s
for a while stay weird say weird yeah
they got caught because one of their
names the one his name was antonio
benitez this is maria
they're
retiring
publicly can enable the enemy to put
pieces together and that can tell us
that guy goes i spy was my little eye
[Laughter]
promos is working this guy where is he
in his basement no seriously i'm like
from the bunker
but let me ask you a question you're a
spy you're that old these people are
probably about 60s yeah when are you
like i gotta just stop spying i don't
want to just get i just want to get when
you're like what else do you want to
know about this [ __ ] country also
they're like russia you want me to spy
you literally put me 5 000 miles off
mainland united states yeah i can tell
you all about honolulu i can't keep up
with the tech yeah i just want to take
some miracles and watch wheel of fortune
i'm 65. i've got no more information
yeah you literally could know more if
you watched hawaii 5.0
[Laughter]
well we should say that they're spies
allegedly
now they were both in the coast guard
for 20 years and retired with benefits
they were the u.s
they were they had security clearances
did they get flipped in prison
well i don't know maybe
they were in our military yeah with fake
social like fake imagine the people that
worked alongside them for 20 years that
they knew their family they like a
friend of 20 years they had to make
friends yeah 100
could you think like in the movies do
you think the whole time
so do they have any real friends or that
by by nature
i live next door to them oh really i
thought it was weird we watched the
movie miracle and they were rooting for
russia
[Laughter]
he's like
and yeah until they put a periscope on
the roof
[Laughter]
yeah it was like it was weird you know
we were sitting day the first day of the
war and we heard cheers from the house
all we heard was the beatles back in the
ussr over and over and over
oh man so do you think by nature of
having to be that an identity to live an
identity that's not your own
how much of your own human biology comes
through and you you do make friends with
the person you worked in the coast guard
with for 20 years in his family and you
have real human connections the whole
time
knowing that everything he knows about
you is completely false like they have
to still make friends right
yeah you can't just be a spy for 20
years and not have real human connection
i would feel if i was like friends with
them in the coast guard like i was a
united states military officer and i was
friends with a russian spies for 20
years i would feel so stupid yeah i'd
like i literally work for the country
and i couldn't pick up that the enemy is
my friend right
but that's probably makes it harder i
guess
have you have you i think i said this to
you a while ago there was an ex-kgb
operative who in 1986 was interviewed
and it's a segment called how to
brainwash a nation oh my god i saw that
you and i spoke about this yes the five
steps on we saw we saw speed up 20
years ago how to demoralize a nation how
to infiltrate a nation and he said none
of it is like this sexy espionage spy
physical it's more
like you infiltrate universities with
communist ideas pump it into the soft
heads of the young kids and then you no
longer have to worry about the
government spying you have citizens
spying on each other which is what's
happening right now well yeah we're
imploding from within yeah totally yeah
yeah yeah yeah
they're released right didn't they say
like you know they start this now but
it's going to pay off in like 20 30
years which is about now because i
genuinely believe this stuff on the
internet it isn't it's not real this
this these things aren't real that the
hate isn't real none of it's real
it's all about well it is hate because
hate begets it's it's stirring up right
it really has a thing
activated it activates our limbic system
yeah yeah yeah the initial start like
the
the atom of it isn't real and then it it
actually you'll see it on a very very
small scale with us you know and i don't
mean i said like i mean like you know
even if we get something that goes viral
it's still like not you know high high
up you'll see
the same comments from different
accounts
five ten times so it's bots but it looks
so real if you just saw one you're like
that's a real person and i hate that
person yeah right and i would tell my
manager watch out for that person don't
let him in the show right when really
they're in a russian troll farm within
yeah
can i can i say just to tap back before
you start plugging your dates about
canceling
that's the sound we love that's the
sound that makes us smile it's the sound
of another sound yes on shopify sound
the shopify
the all-in-one commerce platform to
start run and grow your business i love
it and if you're scared scaling your
business is a journey of endless
possibility which you know it is then
shopify is for you believe me mother
they give entrepreneurs the resources
once reserved for big businesses so
upstart startups and established
businesses alike can sell everywhere
synchronize everything online all their
in-person sales and stay effortlessly
informed 1000
shopify literally it's a lifesaver if
you start in a small business you need
to use shopify it's more than a store
shopify grows with you shopify is a
grower not a shower that's right
look and also you can reach customers
online across all the social networks uh
with their ever growing suite of channel
integrations and apps that's facebook
instagram tick tock pinterest and all
the other ones anyway don't go anything
go periscope they don't care shopify is
wild like that right now if you go to
shopify.com hey babe all lowercase for a
free 14-day trial you will get full
access to shopify's entire suite of
features grow your business with shopify
today go to shopify dot com slash hey
baby all over again right now all our
case right now free 14-day trial
shopify.com hey babe all lowercase
who is it doordash yes
i was starving there it is folks door
dash zero delivery fees used it last
night swear to god
i used doordash
three times a week men really i swear to
g well i literally door dash first of
all door dash deedee this my new double
d's yes
i love doordash you just get the food
from them
ordering your summer essentials with
dash pass by doordash is a great way to
get everything you need you know what
doordash is if you don't you've been
living under an hour yeah that's what it
is
it's a food delivery service but it's
not just food delivery services they can
pick up from chain restaurants mom and
possibly you could also do other things
like get your groceries what do you want
to check
wash your hair look at my meals by cooch
brush your hair if you want to take care
of brush here use door dash to get the
shampoo if you want to order from
doordash but wish you didn't have to pay
the delivery fees dreams do come true
because during summer of dash pass you
can save money and enjoy new members
only offers every week on top of zero
dollars delivery fees all year round
listen shine bright during door dashes
summer of dash pass and get 50
off your first order up to a 15 value
all you got to do is download the
doordash app and use the promo code hey
babe
h-e-y-b-a-b-e checkout when you spend
twelve dollars or more that's 50 off
your first order up to 15 value when you
sign up for door dash during summer of
dash pass use promo code hey babe don't
forget that's code hey babe 50 off your
first order up to 15 value
benefits only on eligible orders that
meet the minimum subtotal terms apply
uh the white would like to chime in yes
rap gets carb launched because people
view it as like cosplaying they view it
as an escape when they make this music
people think that they can escape into
what's being said and everything and
it's this creative endeavor it's not
real which is why with drill rap it's
getting to a point where it's like these
are literal confessions to crimes like
you can no longer separate the the lyric
and the art from the the perception of
reality of whether or not these things
happen comedy is different because
people have a hard time suspending
disbelief like rappers are characters to
people we're not characters we don't
think comedians are characters to people
no we are but we don't get believed by
society that we are like james gunn lost
his job directing guardians of the
galaxy because they found a tweet from
him from 13 years ago that he made a
joke with a like a child
because it's jokes and people go well
there's there's there's truth behind the
joke but with rap also people are very
afraid of looking racist
and i also think that uh dude i did i
did i used to stand up
yes i do agree with with with what you
said about frey look racist but the
argument i make is eminem has crazy that
same award show that kevin hart got
thrown off of kevin hart um eminem
performed on right and eminem's songs
from that era were you know killing his
wife and calling people homos and
everything and he's why maybe it's
because rap makes people [ __ ] money
yeah and and
beyonce's saying spazz in her song
alizzo how's that any different
because women are are subjugated more
than men
because men get away with [ __ ]
i don't know i mean like it's easier to
go and also beyonce bowed down to this
when she shouldn't have you go after
snoop dogg he's not changing [ __ ] right
no he said [ __ ] you he's going to do
more corona commercials yeah and he's
going to do coronita commercials
so much he's on prime time family
programming snoop dogg yeah look at that
family program look at i see look at ice
cube cop killer [ __ ]
the whole nwa thing it means like a
beloved family character it's crazy
people can suspend their disbelief with
that but they take a [ __ ] joke we say
and they're like where's this coming
from you're a bad person people could
get hurt because of this more people
have died because of rap than comedy
ever and it'll never get in trouble and
i don't think it should and i don't
think comedy should either
people playing a video game i can
literally at gunpoint rob a car drive it
into a family get out beat a prostitute
to death save my game play and then go
play with my daughter yeah
that was wait and have your daughter
play with you and watch it right
but but someone's like you know you you
didn't like spazz was it was a word 30
years 40 years ago that was like
in the in the lexicon yeah and and and
people like you're gonna like you take
that down or else it's crazy
yeah it's insane it's a wild world but
it goes back to what the russians
probably did started in the 80s that
video it's all divi it's all this
[ __ ] it's all same thing like with
china how they're like there's no reason
to shoot a bullet at us they've bought
50 of the real estate what was it
a a hundred billion dollars in real
estate assets just last year china so
it's like these countries are like what
they'll kill each other and we own their
land and they don't even care about
their own citizens they'll kill them
yeah they're [ __ ] around they're like
we're sanctioning nancy pelosi that's a
little sanctions
they know that that will get people
talking and fighting with each other
more it's just a daily [ __ ] drip of
fighting and the russians knew they
[ __ ] lost the cold war so they're
like okay weapons out words in pissed
about that they're just about rocky i
believe still they are pissed about i
would be too yeah miracle miracle
my father who's you know 75 years old
has no social media doesn't well i think
maybe we made a page now or somebody
made a page um he he when i was getting
i got in trouble some some hot water for
um a bid i did and i was like kind of
was like bombing me out and my dad was
like do you know any of these people and
i was like i have no idea where any of
my goes i why would you get upset it's
not your friends it's not your family
man of you they don't care what do you
these people are imaginary i was like no
but they're really writing it and this
can happen that could happen he goes
yeah anything can happen
why do not let people you do not know
affect your mood ever and i was like
just i was like just live by that and
you're free right you're actually free
yeah he goes do not let anyone you don't
know affect your mood ever well that's
the whole thing wait that what was that
like huh it's like a ted talk you got a
tony talk yeah well i gotta i gotta
[ __ ] tony talk wow that's actually
what's gonna save my patreon and save my
career
tampa tony talks coming to patreon.com
christie comedy and it's just gonna be
my dad giving advice yeah oh my god
that's [ __ ] great dude put your dad
on like a black stage yeah yeah but it
just says tony
yo do you remember that what was that
like old joke that was like cyber
bullying just turn the computer off it's
like yeah no literally just yeah
you know we we have some friends you
know
getting cancelled to the 10th degree ari
like right got in trouble with all that
stuff i spoke to ari about that he goes
not one person from new york to los
angeles now when you know he made fun of
the kobe death and all that in los
angeles he would they were like you
better never come over here he goes not
one person ever and not one person ever
physically said anything to me because
it just existed online do you know what
he also said he created a fake comedy
club email account and put on fake dates
for these clubs on his website and
people were emailing the club that he
made up going i've been a long time
customer here i come every weekend and i
refuse to come here if ari shafir is
playing your club and it's just an
example of like people are [ __ ] liars
yeah and they're not even going to do
anything one of my friends i didn't even
know like a friend of mine like an
actual real friend of mine his brother
so it's not my friend but he's your
friend
he openly admitted to me that he's an
internet troll he listens to comedy and
he's trolled some of our friends wait
you mean like he's controlling he
identifies as it like he spends his time
doing it he gets joy from it and he does
it sal that's insane you would never in
a million trolls believe this man is a
troll he's got a wife beautiful kids
beautiful wife beautiful family he
literally was like i we were out to
dinner eating something no no he told me
he was like i'm out to dinner we were
out to dinner and i was like you know
talking about kamina i won't name him i
was like oh this guy gets trolled all
the time it's like it hurts and he goes
i i do that he goes i'm not afraid to
admit it i do that and i was like why do
you do that he was like he said to me
he's like because
in my life in my
regular life he goes i feel like [ __ ]
all the time my wife makes more money
than me my kids don't respect me he goes
to the way i get it out anonymously he
goes i have a fake account i told you
this i swear to god with no followers he
goes i like to [ __ ] on comics and
athletes and hopefully he said this i
swear to god they write back to me and
then i can block them and i win and i
feel like i win so it's like this
twisted thing like that he's messed up
in the head and and this is the first i
i have like only one no he told me the
comedians that he shits on he pays to
see them regularly when they come to new
york city wow
and watches them and goes that's even
that's why so i never met a person who
was who was because we always suspected
that but to actually get a concrete
physical flesh humanly like this is why
i do it and then i pay to see them right
and it's crazy like
i you don't know what if you block but
don't respond but just block
but sometimes i'm like i don't want to
block because i know they want the block
yeah so they it's like a badge of honor
to get the block i like so sometimes i
just don't even block but then sometimes
i'm like [ __ ] it
block you in all your accounts like i
don't care just stay out like i if if i
get like hate or something and and i
gotta say knock on wood i'm really
grateful i i don't i might a lot of
people that like me and stuff are very
like kind which i really appreciate it
but there's some real [ __ ] [ __ ]
sometimes and they say some slick
out-of-pocket [ __ ] and i'll literally go
hey i'm a i'm a person like i know you
may like me but you don't respect me and
that's a really hurtful thing to say and
i have feelings and i don't respect it
and that's not okay and and they send
you back the ken jung gif game
they photoshop my head blowing another
guy
yeah that's true
but no most of the time they'll be like
i'm a fan i was trying to roast you i'm
sorry i really they don't
i went through the same thing as you and
it's like these people have such a
disconnect yeah from like reality like
some people just don't know
no
i never ever ever respond to anyone on
the comments but somebody if they dms
once in a while i'm like somebody dm me
the other day they were like oh that bit
that you're trying to say is new which i
wasn't like that bit you're trying to
say is new i heard it last year so
they're a fan of yours and they're
trying to call you
if you knew anything about me you
[ __ ] you wouldn't if you i said if
you knew anything about the bit you
[ __ ] you would know that it's from a
year ago and i posted this from a year
ago and then last night i put thank you
for the support venatia
and then people write back [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
like she's posting on your behalf yeah
well i say on the christie chaos podcast
if any team runs my instagram but it's
not true
people will dm me be like hey venitia
love you what's going on i'm like what
up sir
i'm
she's the most hated woman on the
internet
don't deselve dm chris okay here we go a
track meet turned nsfw which is not safe
for work okay yeah yeah real quick when
italian decathlete alberto no nino
alberto no nino's [ __ ] popped out in the
middle of a race how big does your dick
have to be oh my let's see how big this
guy's [ __ ] it's gonna be blurred
no it better not be
he's oh he's really blowing his holding
it while he's running
and he's catching up
well you use it as leverage is
what if he gets direct just across the
finish line
first now he's like pulling it
it's going to be a photo finish he's
just like oh hey he's italian his nose
would probably cross twice
look he is still popping out just let it
go bro just let it go and win the race
bro he just has to give up now because
his dick
look he's giving up
he's gonna come in last just because of
your cards
everyone has it that poor fella he comes
in
is but it did come last
third
look at the guy falling he tripped over
his dick
what do you think he says in the post
game interview he's like well i tried to
run a good eraser but my penis
look at that dog i want to see the video
i trained there for four years i wake up
every day at the 5 am and then my dick
they pop it up
you never think about the idiot
this is the only thing
i did not even get the problems yes but
i have an only fence
now couple arrested for giving vodka
shot oh my god look at that look at that
picture on the right hold on hold on
hold on look at that picture on the
right dude it's the babies i understand
that this is looks bad but
i have two questions one are they
teething too are they russian
[Laughter]
also why would you film this yeah put it
online
dude no do you realize how stupid people
are we're gonna watch this video because
how dumb [ __ ] people are
there's a cops um or emt workers that
are going to get fired from their job
rightfully so they had someone tied to a
um
to uh
uh uh stretcher and i guess he was drunk
or whatever and they were ra they were
having him say funny things into the
radio over the dispatch and filming it
and one of them posted on their tick
tock it's like are you a stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ]
like people don't get it you can't
breach that [ __ ] you're trying to do it
when i was a physical therapist and this
was back in the day before social media
is even big people would po like people
i worked with would post videos of the
children that we work with on their
facebook
look at what so and so did it's like
that kid had special needs right and i'm
not like a rap to go that people don't
get one time because they were like
dancing around this girl that had down
syndrome like it would and i was like
stop doing wait why were they dancing
they were they were trying to undounce
her they were making an ancient
rain dance
they were they were trying to make this
girl with down syndrome who worked with
like not trying to make the she was
dancing like she was like oh and they
were having fun with it yeah yeah but it
was going like it was like two crates
like they were videoing her like shaking
her ass i'm like this girl's like and
then laughing she's also 11. i was like
what what are we doing here so i said
you guys got to stop this like [ __ ]
making me this is like weird yeah and
then you know i you know they were like
oh like kind of like looking at me like
i was some kind of [ __ ] rat i was
like i'm sorry i don't want to see an 11
year old girl with down syndrome shaking
her ass and you're putting it on
facebook i was like i'm in the
caroline's comedy competition i don't
want to get disqualified
i really i can't [ __ ] work here
anymore
um this is disturbing okay so this is uh
this is uh rap music plays in background
they're playing snoop dogg in the back
yeah look how red the baby oh my god
he's [ __ ] wasted oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh that is so wrong dude but
is it water could you imagine that
i'm trying to process that it's probably
not vodka though is this a second shot
or like they g that's the same thing
repeated i mean dude people in oh my
programs of recovery talk about how this
they ordered them
into a life of alcoholism and degeneracy
is it but is this is it real chris or is
it uh russia did it happen for real
they're saying a woman believe each can
be seen poor she then shockingly gives
you the baby and tilts the tykes head
back so it goes down a la cough sierra a
shirtless man thought to be the boy's
father can be seen standing nearby
oblivious to the baby's boozing session
go down i guarantee you though that it
says it
it says it appeared that way so it's
allegedly
let's do one with us come on
oh i like that you put english on it
have been let unfortunately the bozos
they should have called them
how could how could he get that child
back that's like how could they get that
child back
this is in they live in yeah i know this
is
uk don't give up
child services has been alerted to the
situation
they've taken appropriate action what oh
my god that is the that is infuriating
to me what wait
indonesian in indonesia and if it lit up
the internet after video emergency room
indulging it is 40 cigarette per day
habit
how did they get that video of me as a
kid yeah
let's uh i've always seen that i've seen
i've seen this and it's and it's and
it's disturbing it's no it's it is
disturbing it's disturbing
physically
i said it's disturbing i have the same
physique
[Laughter]
that's great
oh my god look at him i mean they also
put him in a leather jacket
is that the rocketeer
what a good movie oh yeah
he's moving he's doing cigarettes
oh my god he is holding court ripping
dude
the weird thing is is he holds it like
an adult so it's like oh dude oh no yes
he's he's oh dude
he's monkey butting it that's what you
gotta do dawg that's the way oh my god
look at his little girlfriend right
there like he's a boy i think
oh my god i mean that's that milk son oh
yeah
then they give him literal bottle of
formula
lays down chills arrest those people man
arrest them arrest them
what they're [ __ ] national heroes
yeah that kid's cool as hell
oh actress oh and hey
oh hey this is ellen's wife what
or it is no it was intubated after what
happened no
severely burned and fiery oh and
what's that red circle on the in the
left picture just right now this
happened
oh that's so what's the red
um let's see
come on i love ann haish who doesn't
you're a piece of [ __ ] if you don't love
anthony i just made an ann hayes
reference on the shark week special this
week really yeah do you think you have
anything to do with this
no if you don't like andrew that's why
she was mad i hate you you [ __ ]
mentioned me on youtube tank
oh my god so what happened
car accident jesus christ i hope what
was the significance of that thing in
her car was it one of those things that
you blow like alcohol into or something
that's what i thought they were getting
at oh yeah well that could be
a bottle was seen
in asia's cup holder okay but it could
be a bottle of anything yeah it could
have been that smoking baby's foreign
enhance
enhance see what it is it looks like
smearing off no
okay
they think it was alcohol do you think
it's yoga they think it's yakov smirnoff
i can't make that out in any way shape
or form i don't get it i don't see like
a pint of liquor
oh it's a i can't see it yeah i don't
see that but that's what you get if
someone took a photo of her
moments before she crashed that's where
you get to keep it in a glove box
that's the way to go out pimping pimping
ian just point to each other with the
glove box reference they know where to
keep their alcohol trash yeah you keep
the pine in the glove box oh i love it
and then you leave the sun roof open so
you can tilt it all the way back
you're an addict really yeah okay there
you go
you're nice dude
i love that we've shown both your baby
videos
the cigarette one and the vodka shots
yeah oh nice and you know what
we're having a movie night oh
wow
is that a nail file or a knife it's a
letter opener oh wow you ever pulled
that out on somebody no but i wish a
[ __ ] would wow
got it in ohio didn't bring it on the
flight had a guy drive it back to new
york
and i also got two tasers brass knuckles
which is a belt buckle a friend of mine
got assaulted in tribeca midday so i got
her a taser and i'm going home late at
night it's crazy it's my 12 year old
stepson's birthday yeah birthday last
week
one of his uncles bought him a a full
real state-of-the-art full machete what
he has a machete as real as can be
upstairs with my seven-year-old daughter
oh my one-year-old daughter running
around he fully came home from his dad's
house was like look at my dad look what
i got and i was like what is it buddy
and then he pulled out a for real
machete
and i was like holy [ __ ] and his mom is
furious oh i bet so what would he do
you put it like above the fridge or
something right you yeah i mean but whoa
it's iron clad he can't get to it above
the fridge well well the rule is now he
has it but it's at it's pop's house now
he's like she's like honestly
he's in his phone
he came home and i got to be honest with
you even though like obviously you know
trying to be data protected my kids was
like can i hold it yeah i was like
i was like delilah back up and i [ __ ]
ripped it out dude i have a machete
upstairs
bespokepost.com i got it from bespoke
post oh shut up
shout out to smokeblocks
yeah you're gonna get the smoke post to
sponsor your pod i'll do it be an ian
pod patreon.com slash beanie and pod
what spokesmost
so what's your strategy with that what
the [ __ ] are you gonna do with that
thing what no i like it it just gives
you a little sense of security you hit
somebody in the neck with that that
they're done they're done hey i i got
you you're done if some guy comes up on
me oh my last thing i'd like to do i
gotta go
please sir before i can i just comb my
stats can i just comb can i just hygiene
myself please i i they don't even let
you have peppa's gene
you tried to bring that into russia what
do you think would happen oh they
wouldn't find it be up my hands
we
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say